there is news ian rapper for the nfl
reporting and i suspect there'll be 50
other reports to that same effect and
then a statement in about five minutes
or less giants coach pat shurmur out
after two seasons this one was widely
expected just like freddy kitchens those
are the two that we flagged last night
the expected firings not a surprise
silence from the organization becomes
deafening especially when you consider
teams like the lions the jets the
falcons making it clear that guys are
back when the browns and the giants
don't do it you know it's coming and it
comes for pat shurmur your reaction
chris well yeah not shocked at all uh
really not you know i think there's two
things that will uh just ring true to me
at least with pat shimmer of course the
results on the field were not good right
so that's the first thing and then the
second thing and this was commonplace
mike i know you heard this from people
up here too you know he just didn't
endear himself to the fan base and the
people of the tri-state area the giants
fans everything that may be within press
conferences and things like that i think
those are two big areas that he lost
those battles and that's why he's no
longer the head coach of the new york
giants and uh i think this was the right
move you know i think we had seen enough
i knew it was going to be a failure from
the get-go did you i knew it was going
to be a fairy from the get-go when mike
holmgren who was shermer's boss in
cleveland right as shermer was getting
himself in position to be a head coach
again when holmgren's take is shermer
needs to calm down when mike holmgren of
all people is taking the position that
anyone needs to calm down that tells me
that shermer is wound a little too tight
yes and and i i
i never interviewed him during his time
with the johnson and all the guy i think
i did back when he was at the browns and
i detected then he was if i recall
correctly he had like no sense of humor
no nonsense which is fine if that's who
you are that's fine i'm just saying
it's a little you know
there's a point where it's not going to
serve you well in the new york market
and it did not serve him well nine and
23 with the giants nine and 23 with the
browns and here's the key
ben mcadoo was 13 and 15. yeah you're
right i mean went to the playoffs two
weeks ago and got fired during the
season right it was clear then that
shermer's out the real question is where
did the giants go
from here now that shermer is out and gm
dave gettleman there was a suggestion
yesterday from jay glaser or fox that
gentleman is safe you've raised the
point that it could be an impediment to
the giants getting who they want as the
head coach i think the giants have
always done the strong gm right right
right would they be inclined to maybe
give a coach more power do they think
maybe this model is outdated where
you've got that strong gm who runs the
team that maybe you should have a strong
coach who's got more say in how the team
is running well it's a very interesting
question and i do think we're in an era
more of you know hey head coaches want
to run the team or of course there's
just a great relationship between the
head coach and the gm you know i'll uh
let's just say the seattle seahawks john
carroll i mean pete carroll john
schneider they work well together of
course pete carroll has a lot to say and
what they do john schneider listens to
what kind of players he wants and he
goes out and gets them drafts them signs
them via free agency i think that is an
issue with the new york giants you know
i know that i don't have to think i know
that i know enough people and coaches in
the nfl that are just go
yeah that's a great job it's the new
york giants and all that but i don't
want it if dave gettleman's there and
listen some of what dave gettleman's
done is building that football team is
questionable too so i would not be
shocked if they let him go uh some point
here in the next you know
week or a few days whenever it may be
and again i just turned to a guy where i
always think of the giants the giants
there's a great relationship between the
maras and bill belichick
gosh josh mcdaniels is there with the
new york i mean with the new england
patriots he
groomed and was a part of a guy like tom
brady
daniel jones has a lot of tom brady
attributes to him if anybody's watched
the giants this year you can see daniel
jones there's some specialness about his
play i mean he was a guy that i
completely got wrong in my draft
evaluation i'll tell you that much he's
been awesome that's a big time name on
your phone right there looking at my
phone he does that all the time the big
time name calling him right now let me
just say it you almost wound up my
big-time name i called me a few minutes
ago uh but uh yeah it's uh i'm turning
my phone over just in case now um but
but uh yeah i i look at that to be a
you know the giants are run a lot like
new england i think that would make a
lot of sense to me and the other name i
always hear with the giants
is uh matt rule down in baylor he did
work with the giants for a little bit
he's a northeast guy he understands the
new york area the media everything that
goes along with it there and he's kind
of a no-nonsense real football coach
those are the two names i hear a lot and
you know me mike i'm more of a fan of
josh mcdaniels than anybody else and you
know we talked earlier about josh
mcdaniels being a candidate in cleveland
uh and a candidate in carolina
and and last year
the browns did an interview yeah josh
mcdaniels i think that there was some of
that some of that
residue of what happened with the colts
that was causing people to shy away from
mcdaniels and maybe now that we're two
years removed and maybe now that there's
a sense that it's coming to an end in
new england yeah maybe there's a sense
that steve belichick is the heir to bill
belichick not josh mcdaniels right that
maybe people think mcdaniels will
actually i mean the reality is this he
can't leave another team at the altar
yeah you don't have to worry about josh
mcdaniels telling you sorry i'm not
coming what you have to do worry about
though is him having regrets and
following through if he doesn't really
want the job and then he's there and and
doesn't want to be there and that's the
one thing chris ballard the gem of the
cults always felt good about it was
better to find out josh mcdaniels wanted
out right before he was there right and
then everybody's stuck so i think that's
the risk you have now if he's not 100
sure and he takes one of these jobs he's
not going to leave you at the altar but
you may have some dysfunction if he
decides it's just not for him but i
think that people are starting to get to
the point where they're realizing that
he is at some point going to make that
jump so maybe yeah whether it's the
giants the browns the panthers maybe
we're the team he should jump yeah well
and i think you know one thing that
probably josh is going to learn and the
nfl is going to learn that you know this
is a guy again too that's just uh he's
not going to do that again he's not
going to commit to anything until he
knows this is really what i want to do
my family's all in josh has a lot of
kids he's got a wife that you know
they're very cohesive and work together
so uh i i would only think he's going to
entertain jobs and prospects that really
makes sense to him from here on out and
keep this in mind two years ago when the
job was open with the giants they
interviewed eric studentsville steve
spagnolo matt patricia steve wilkes and
josh mcdaniel yeah so they interviewed
him two years ago now makes sense
institutionally you know he said good or
is that bad yeah you know he maybe they
wanted him and he chose the colts and he
spurned the cults i don't know they
ended up with pat shurmur but now's the
opportunity to go back to that well and
maybe bring in i had always heard that
you know the giants and josh it was
close to happening and there were just a
few little things behind the scenes that
you know they couldn't see eye to eye on
and that's why the marriage never really
happened but uh i i definitely know
there was some serious flirting the
first time around what do you think of
the talent right now the talent of the
giants well i i you know you have to be
excited about the running back in the
quarterback the offensive line needs
you know needs help
you know that's where i look at dave
gettleman and go okay you know
you know gave all that money to nate
solder you know will hernandez a top of
the second round pick uh out of utep he
hasn't been great you know there's some
other issues there the giants have some
rebuilding to do so that's where it's
going to be important that they get a
coach that either wants to work with
gettlemen to improve the team or they
get a coach in there and you just clean
clean clean house and you let you know
the new head coach have a gm that they
work that they like and they can rebuild
this thing but there's a lot of areas i
mean the secondary's not good
linebackers aren't good no pass rusher
here's the thing when they won the super
bowl to cap the 2007 and 2011 season
what were their biggest strengths
offensive defensive line right what do
they what are their biggest weaknesses
now right yeah you're exactly right mike
that's spot on the only thing they got
is some big people a defensive tackle
but you're right they're not the giants
that we know
where whether it was my dad's era with
bill parcells where you know yeah the
giants are famous for going we're big
we're bad we're the new york giants
we're big blue we got big dudes up front
and you're gonna have to fight us and
they don't have that right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports